from the midwest i've lived here for a
little while now and this is a new thing
where
like late at night on the street
uh women will see me as a threat
that is funny yeah that is funny
it's kind of flattering in its own way
but at the same time it's weird because
like i'm still afraid of being kidnapped
you know
but i'll give you the best example of
this a couple months ago i'm at a subway
station in
long island city queens oh yeah
do go if you get the chance a beautiful
place
i'm changing between subway trains right
and it's two o'clock in the morning okay
and you have to walk down this long
corridor in order to change trains
two o'clock in the morning it's just me
and this woman
and she's walking a few yards ahead of
me and we're walking down and she
starts giving me like the over the
shoulder like that you know like look at
him
and then she starts to pick up the pace
she starts to walk a lot faster
so i think oh she must hear the train
coming
you know or she feels it in her feet
like a native american in a movie
so i start to sprint down the hallway
and she looks back and she's like and
then she gives chase so now we're like
booking it down the corridor
at two o'clock in the morning and i'm
gaining on her
i'm gaining on her and we're getting to
the end of the hallway and she's going
into that like dead end
shuffle you know that women do when you
chase them and i'm almost there
i'm almost at her and then it dawns on
me
oh she's running from me
because in her eyes i'm an adult
and adults rape each other
kind of a lot so i wanted to go up to
her and be like whoa
no no no no i'm not like
a like a
i'm not a man
i'm just some stupid punk right but i
think that that would be equally creepy
as if you were in a subway station at
two o'clock in the morning
and i chased you down and grabbed you
and said
i'm not gonna rape you i'm a little boy
[Applause]
people wouldn't like that either i tell
you i tell you a funny [ __ ] on yourself
story not this isn't be the guy with the
[ __ ] jokes uh steven seagal right steve
is a girl
uh i'm doing uh that's another movie
so what are you teaching how to do no
this is this is gonna kill you i promise
you
i'm gonna kill you so we're doing uh
we're doing ride along two
cube accidentally punched one of the
stunt guys right in the nose
q who's cube ice cube another i gotta
introduce you he'll love it
he punches the stunt guy in the nose
stunt guy's nose starts bleeding q is
apologetic yo man i'm so sorry god i'm
sorry i think no no man it's okay like
at least you're nice you know like i
know that it wasn't intentional
we've worked with people in the past
that have been just dicks right
so he's like who i'm like who else he's
like with steven's goal you know he used
to really
get shots in you know in these scenes so
got to the point where we had to come to
our boss you know the stunt coordinator
we were like
hey man steven's really hitting us like
can you kind of tell him to
sound like he's lied down his wife said
the same thing
can you tell steve to relax a little bit
so stephen found out that one of the
guys
was like a black belt in judo like a a
serious black belt so stephen comes up
to the guy he's like hey
put me in your best hold i bet you i can
get out of it and he's like i can't do
that you know you
you're my boss i can't do that to you
he's like put me in your best hole
he looks at his balls because steven was
being a dick the guy said go ahead do it
choke steven put him in a chokehold
right
stephen's struggling his feet his feet
squaming
he's searching for balance he can't it's
like
he's losing air a little bit but you
know the you got to tap out well you
don't want anymore so
while you're here
all you hear is
[Music]
[Laughter]
he taps out he taps out
it goes good good old and he's just he
belongs
to the bathroom he he comes out
it smells like [ __ ] everywhere the guy
choked the [ __ ] out of stuff he's
literally all years
touring with comedy central all over the
country 50 states you guys in a tour bus
every city every state has been amazing
everything was going so smooth
until we passed through phoenix
i gotta tell you what happened okay
we're on our way to california and in
between the two you know
there's a checkpoint where they're
looking for illegals narcotics
weapons or all three if you're
convenient
and we're rolling through
it's pretty good huh anyway i know i did
a good bus because when i went
she's like this
he's really good it's really good i saw
the bus i saw it
anyways it's uh it's early in the
morning and we're rolling through we get
pulled over and the
immigration officer walks over the
window and you know
our driver you know he's like what's
going on here and our driver right
cool dude named dave he's been driving
tour buses for like 30 years
he's old and white and he doesn't care
like his favorite line is
and i'm giving
good old dave right so the officer is
like what's going on and dave is like
it's a comedian gabriela iglesias and
his entourage comedians
it's sponsored by comedy central it's
legit
and as they're talking we hear this
outside
hold on our dog has just informed us
that there is something inside this tour
bus that is not supposed to be here
and our driver looks at the immigration
officer and he says is that what he said
scooby
scooby-doo
and we're in the back having a heart
attack dave you're gonna get us arrested
next thing you know they asked the
representative of the tour bus to get
off so my name and my face are on the
side of the bus
door pops open and i'm greeted by an
immigration officer with the last name
sanchez traitor
not only did he recognize me the guy was
starstruck because as soon as he saw me
he was like
and when i saw that i said oh this is
going to be easy right we'll take some
pictures i'll sign some autographs and
we'll go
here comes the other guy with the dog
right
hey what's on the bus and i look at
sanchez and he's still
i didn't think nothing of it you know
he's like what's on the bus i'm just
more mexicans
i didn't know all right i knew i messed
up because i look at sanchez and he's
like
next thing you hear freaking everybody
off the bus
martin my friend alfred my friend noe
freaking one little two little three
little mexicans four and
a five little six
everybody off the bus and then they put
us up against the side of the bus so
they could frisk us
for narcotics and weapons guys in the
back show the picture
now notice notice you don't see a white
bus driver in the picture
it's cause he took the picture
apparently even after talking smack to
immigration he was still considered an
innocent bystander
you guys can you show the next one
that's sanchez
trainer show the next one
there's a dog and there's where we threw
it
trust me they did not catch me with
anything because my guys are fast
oh yeah if they would have popped me
with something on that freaking tour bus
are you kidding you guys would have
heard all about it
that sucker would have been on tmz uh-oh
fluffy's doing puffy
i'm gonna tell you guys the saddest part
of that whole situation was being on the
side of the road
being harassed by immigration okay
meanwhile there are cars driving past
the same checkpoint
and i'm getting recognized and not only
am i fairly recognizable from almost any
angle
i'm touching a bus that has my name and
my face to confirm
that's who we thought it was so i'm
against the bus and this guy's got his
hand on my butt and meanwhile from
behind i hear this
fluffy
he's american
[Applause]
damn i also had a house breaking this is
a true story right
me and another comic called steve hughes
was sitting at home and i kid you not
this is what happened uh two guys came
through the window one with a hammer one
with a machete if you look at the side
of my head
i got like a scar there yeah yeah they
cut my head right
they tied us up and all that type of
stuff then they drove off out of my
house
and they got caught speeding in my car
before we ever made
the the call or whatever right they're
now serving 12 years in prison for
grievous body harm
aggravated burglary um attempted rape
and possession
i thought i couldn't get away with
getting into graphic detail but listen
to us
it's like oh it's your girlfriend all
right
why attempted was he nervous or what
happened no because they they left
before and they held the knife to her
throat and they
the cops just weren't pretty they also
got him for possession of drugs right
which was brilliant because they were my
drugs right
they stole like a little bag of weed and
a gram of coke that my flatmate had
right
and the cops are questioning us and they
go uh mr jeffries one last thing do you
know anything about those drugs oh yeah
you're going to admit to that
no i don't know anything about him and
the cop goes funny your fingerprints
were all over them
and i went they made me touch it
that's the attempted rape
that's probably how they got caught
they're like what's that he knew but he
just let it go because
oh yeah the cops were laughing about it
afterwards right and these two blokes
got 12 years man it's a long sentence
and the thing is when they broke into a
house they thought we were drug dealers
me and me
me now the mate the other kind they
thought we drugged us because
well i i have the lifestyle of a drug
dealer i just i never seem to go to work
i drive a nice car
if someone knocks on the door at three
in the afternoon i'll answer in my
underwear eating a bowl of cereal
i mean that's drug dealer behavior right
or a comedian
they just assume and they came in and
when they were tying me up i thought
they were going to tie everyone else up
in the house right
so i i acted like they were doing it a
bit tight on my wrist so that when
everyone else was tied up
i could break free and do some of my
moves right
but that turned out they only tied me up
you know when they got pulled over
that's probably how they got caught was
the drugs because they got pulled over
and it's just speeding it's just okay
and then we're gonna search the car
oh there's drugs here ah those aren't
mine who are they
they belong to the guy who i just tied
up and tried to wipe the straw from all
yeah they went for a big high speed
check there's at one stage during the
break
i don't know i can speak about this now
the court case over right one one stage
during the case right mom on the ground
tied up when my head's been cut and the
other flat mates laying on the ground
my girlfriend's laying under the duvet
in the bed the the nicer one out of the
two blokes right good guy right he he
walks over
to like the chester drawers and i've got
like pictures of my nephews and nieces
and he picks up one of the pictures he
goes either you guys got kids right
and my best mate he doesn't have a kid
goes
five-year-old boy and i thought i'm
laying on the ground bleeding they're
going to kill me now i'm the one they're
going to kill
yeah because he's got kids yeah so i
went
four-year-old girl and then we tried to
trump each other
and i swear to god i'm pregnant
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
he uh what happened was i've also got a
scar on top of my finger
and that that there was one guy who's
really sadistic with a machete was like
a like a sugar cane cutting one like a
big curve
sort of two foot two inches and they
tied me up head to feet
and then my mate sort of made a bit of a
a sort of a lunge at him trying to
[ __ ]
sorry oh we'll try and try and try
trying to fix
my mate made a bit of a lunge at him
trying to fix all the problems and all
that type of stuff
so the guy said don't do that again and
slice the side of my head right
and then and then blood was pumping out
of my head just into like a puddle in
front of me
and i'm tired and you think you'd be
really nervous but under that much
pressure the human brain just leaves
like literally my head was just going
down
nothing had happened at all my
girlfriend's crying under the thing and
then he tied me up with
the power cord from my girlfriend's hair
straighteners
and then when they cut me free she
didn't cry when they said they were
going to rape her
right when she saw that power cord was
cut she was upset she was like you can
only get this brand in america
i had to order away for these i
swear to god this story is true i'm not
making this they were going to rape her
and they just left
they were doing it more to talk to us
why why they were in the house i don't
think that really they ever really were
but the cops just want to slap as much
on them
wow you need guns and uh
you need guns in your house yeah yeah
that's a big fan of them oh yeah
the thing is the first thing i know i'm
sitting in my living room chair and then
the guy comes through the window on the
second story and no alarm no well the
second story was
open we were in the house no alarm yeah
but you don't have an alarm on while
you're walking through your house push
it
up no guns right no going everywhere
no no so the guy put the [ __ ] i was just
sitting around in my underwear
he's there with the he's there with the
knife to me throat going
get me your car keys get me a car keys
and i'm like look man
every morning it takes me a little while
to find him
let me rummage for a moment